there is still some
biological uh benefits to being born a
man versus being born a female athletes
are and male athletes are the best like
mma female athletes cis have male
training partners and most of the time
like they're kicking their ass unless
like they're oh we're good we're good
we're good we're good
we're good today's topic jubilee jubilee
hi my name is howard i've been a swimmer
for 13 years and currently i'm on the
ucla triathlon team my name is jing and
i've been swimming for 11 years hi i'm
lexi i've been playing indoor volleyball
for seven years i've been playing beach
volleyball for three years
my name is afton i play women's flat
track roller derby and i've been playing
since the end of 2018 trans athletes
have an unfair advantage step forward if
you agree
let me make this clear
trans women have an unfair advantage
trans men have an unfair disadvantage
you first think about like transgender
athletes i guess the first thing you
think about is well biologically
transition usually happens
after puberty right so
if this biologically
male athlete goes through puberty
he gets like better bone structure he
has all these skills that he enhances um
at least muscle that he puts on and then
he transitions
um yes your testosterone levels go down
but you're always just gonna have that
like things that you've gone through
like during puberty that you have after
you that's pretty much where the video
ends but good job to her she's correct i
think it's dependent on the gender that
they are transitioning to for example
trans women do have somewhat of an
advantage biological men are naturally
born with higher bone density and larger
lung capacity and a larger heart and
that's not something that can
necessarily be changed with hormones of
course this isn't the same for
trans uh men athletes for me it's just
on average guys are typically a little
bit stronger a little bit larger a
little bit taller
so depending on the sport especially it
can give them a large advantage when
you're looking at something like that
when it's something like swimming having
that ability to be a little bit larger
larger lung capacity will overall affect
that
can i have the disagree or step forward
among cisgender men and cisgender women
there are
naturally
differences in their anatomy in their
hormonal levels in their
height bone structure all that stuff
like any cisgender woman compared to
another might have a different body type
some women are naturally very strong if
you take
the advantage which i think
in most cases is the hormones and if you
compare the blood work and you're just
looking at that if they're on the same
level in my opinion there just isn't an
advantage because that's not what we're
looking at you're saying yeah but if we
look at if we look at two people that
have the same things then you know
there's no disadvantage i understand
that
that's not what the issue is though
you're right but that's not what the
issue is you didn't address any of the
things these people said about lung
capacity bone density exactly muscle
twitch fiber's like
that's not the issue and if you guys
want don't listen to me there's like
i'll link to some of the studies in the
description but
you just you talked about hormones you
didn't mention anything about going
through puberty as a male if if we match
two people that are exactly the same but
are different genders yeah you're going
to have the same thing but that's not
what we're talking about if you guys are
wondering why i'm like this is because
i've seen this discussion happen like
four or five times yeah there's the same
disingenuous arguments yeah just haven't
addressed the concerns that these
females have you haven't and you gloss
over it with these like nonsense well
there's really like no even playing
lyfield in sports at all so what should
we get rid of weight classes by that
logic should should a lightweight fight
a heavyweight yeah so it's like you know
some light weights are stronger than
some like weaker middle really
is that what you're saying do you think
a heavyweight one lightweight wants to
fight a heavyweight by your logic get
rid of all categories sensors come on
this is not a good argument the problem
i see with this argument is that there's
a large group of people that no matter
what i do in a sport will always
automatically assume that i have an
advantage but they're not taking into
account hours that i put into practice
everybody had put these hours that's the
thing and it doesn't make you less good
at what you do you're good at what you
do but you do have an advantage on top
of the hours that you put it's not just
the event you come in with the advantage
is that you come here with all the hours
that you had put in great immense hours
right immense hours a lot of of um
discipline that you have on top of that
you add the advantage that you have
we're not disputing that it's just that
everybody has those always
those big hours on on set everybody in
that field does but you after that come
up with that you want to know how
ridiculous you imagine a heavyweight who
was competing with lightweights and then
people said that's unfair and he says
well you're not going to take into
consideration all the hard work and all
the time i put in nobody said you didn't
work hard we're just saying you have a
physiological advantage and that's why
we have these categories and you don't
apply for this category period nobody
said that these women can't beat you
from time to time
if you go to jiu jitsu class and you got
a huge man who's a black belt and a
small man who's a black belt guess what
most of the time the big man is going to
win if he's really skilled at what he
does and they have about equal amount of
skill but sometimes the little guy's
going to win every now and then doesn't
change the fact that they should be at
different weight classes absolutely even
for jiu jitsu they have different weight
classes i got one of my friends she does
i mean she's been doing a lot longer
than i did
and she could have a field trip on my
butt butt like you said before because
she's been yeah so you go ronda round on
youtube yes
exactly yeah but then if i start to
train and put the same hours then i'm
gonna have an advantage because [ __ ]
and you guys have to imagine like sports
comes down to such thin margins
take sprinting
talking about milliseconds the
difference between 9.58
and point seven eight is huge this is
just nice it's huge and a hundred meter
dash is huge and so when you're talking
about
ten percent faster or nine percent
faster
it's
amazing immense
roller derby is probably 90 plus percent
cis women i get my ass handed to me
yes i i am tall and i can i can see that
that can be an advantage in some sports
but it doesn't necessarily
guarantee that i have an advantage
nobody says it guarantees
the categories are there to protect
people on averages
again this is why it bothers me
these takes are disingenuous
either these people aren't
knowledgeable enough about this whole
thing to have a sensible discussion
about it or they're being purposefully
disingenuous the feeling comes into play
and it's the feeling that guide them you
know i mean and i get that i can
understand because in their position
it's very hard because you try to be
someone you're not you want to live in
the gender yes you're not you're not who
you want like you who you are you know
what i mean and you just strive to be
exactly you try to be in line with
yourself and you can and that's just
hard on everything on the moral law and
everything and i get that but what we
usually hear in the like news and like
politics and stuff is about trans women
just because they're in so much
prominence because they're they are
winning like i can't remember what her
name is right now but she was a power
lifter she is a parliamentary i think
she went to tokyo olympics and she's
transgender and um they're winning by
like a large amount like of weight if
you truly believe that trans women have
an advantage even with hormones then
that means you truly believe that trans
men have a disadvantage even with
hormones yes yeah thank you
yes and guess what you don't hear about
trans men flourishing in male sports
there's a non-binary point to one who
made it to the olympics and actually did
have decent you won't point to one who's
really won records and beat out their
male counterparts you won't
the reason why you won't is because they
have a disadvantage in the in the
canadian soccer team there is a
non-binary person that is playing with
uh the women's soccer team assign women
at birth now she's non-binary she's
playing with one
i don't see her playing whoa man
on the soccer team
she wouldn't be able to get on the
soccer team
and this is no disrespect to these
people the reason why serena williams
can't beat the 115th ranked male okay
i'm not gonna talk about she can't even
win a single single set it's not us it's
not because she's not extremely tapped
or she doesn't work hard it's just
built different blah blah blah you guys
get it
so the argument that you hear most of
the time is against trans women so does
that mean that you're okay with trans
men having that disadvantage no we're
not okay with trans women trans man
having that advantage or the
disadvantage it's not fair so even for
i wouldn't have a trans man fight with
another man that's a disadvantage
and that that's not safe for them either
you know what i mean yeah that's exactly
what it means i'm glad you got that i
hope it was not sarcasm though when i
was going through high school um i
wrestled against females i had to
suppress both my hormones my body and i
was still able to beat the men too with
my leg levels low like i cut 15 pounds a
week like that and that that was crazy
that's what i guess i'm saying like the
body is like a shell and what we do
every single day in the practices and
the like life lessons that we get like
living 40 years on this earth you know
we certainly like it
you didn't say anything you said nothing
the behind is a shell bro guys guess
what we're not all built different some
people are genetically guilted
sorry you're not built like lebron james
you never get to play the same you mean
no matter how hard you work some of you
are just never going to get that when it
comes to athletics it's patently unkind
um yes hard work goes into it
undoubtedly discipline matters a lot
what you're genetically gifted with if
you're not built like michael phelps
good luck beating him my shane my shell
ain't never gonna be six eight so it's
not happening trans athletes should have
a separate category in certain sports
what do you think yeah yeah yeah
because they still need to compete
something that they need they need to
strive but but yeah they need to have a
different category i'm not gonna lie to
you this video is really uninteresting
because unfortunately the trans folks
didn't come with any decent arguments no
so i'm kind of just losing interest
that's the thing i understand i
understand
i do understand i wish they would have
brought somebody who had different
arguments or could actually argue
against what the other person was
because there is no middle ground no
they're just taking
what they're saying and talking next to
it yeah they're like talking here when
the point was right there yeah so the
response doesn't match what the first
initial question was so it's really not
i want to say that they should be in a
completely different category just
because socially and legally yes they
are
that gender that they transition to and
putting them in another category just
seems from hindsight seems wrong but as
an athlete like in the sporting world it
just does seem a little bit unfair if
you classify them
under the same group i guess let's be
clear about something
there is legally
in socially women
they are not female by any stretch in
any means you cannot transition your sex
only your gender
and sports is not a matter of gender
identity it's a matter of sex there's
some okay when they say women's sport
they're not talking about your gender
expression or the hair that you like to
wear when they say women sports they
mean the female anatomy they're talking
about biological females competing as
biological females just because we
didn't have the language to represent
these ideas when we first created these
sporting categories does not mean that's
not what they were meant for i think
sometimes people conflate the whole idea
of gender and sex not realizing that
just because you transition does not
mean you change your sex there is no
trans person who can say that they
change their sex you can change your
characteristics you can change your hair
you can even do hormone therapy you're
never going to have the biology of a
female this is not to be denigrating
it's not to be mean i'm not that's not
my train whatever pronoun you want me to
use fine you want to be acknowledged as
a woman not an issue
but women's sport is really just
synonymous for female sports that's what
it's meant to represent
so
let's be very careful when we say well
they're socially has nothing to do with
how they're legally viewed because even
when they go to the doctor
the doctor
when treating their issues and their
health problems will not just look at
them as a
woman they have to see like were you
born a female and if you weren't there's
certain issues that male deal with that
you need to be treated for and you need
to be scanned for okay there's no doctor
who is responsible who can look at you
and be like well i'm going to treat you
like a woman in terms of your medical
problems that's ridiculous right so
let's just understand that difference
and again i'm not saying this to be like
oh you're not it's not that just
understand the difference between sex
and gender i think sometimes i'm like
what it's like it's like women's
bathrooms
they're female bathrooms yes right
the reason why there's no standing point
to piss
in the female bathroom
or the women's bathroom is because it's
meant for the female anatomy
that's all there is to it people are
using like modern day language and new
things that we're learning about now to
kind of conflate the conversation about
things that have been here before that
language even existed it's it makes the
whole discussion confusing and blurry
yes yeah i think that there definitely
are some sports where your physical
ability makes a much larger impact on
the sport itself wrestling would be one
of them swimming track something like
that but if you look at nascar as a
sport i believe that anyone can then go
and do that sort of sport because that's
more of a technique even nascar
it's not going to be just about the
technique it's going to be how you're
going to take g-forces and someone with
a more bone density it's going to be
able to perform better it's not just
driving they think that formula one is
just driving it's not just that it's
first you have to have your weight and
you have to have how you take those
g-forces that's why in nice car there
hasn't been a lot of women then nikki
patrick is one of them she's phenomenal
but she's one of them because she's
because she can take out her weight she
can take the g-forces a certain way it's
a lot of stress on the body and you have
to have a certain body to do that f1 is
not just going around a racetrack it's
almost similar to
someone piloting a jet almost sometimes
if you look at other sports like
golf it all requires a lot of technique
and a lot of strength plus video games
now starting to make a massive rise so
all of those could definitely have both
genders in it with no problem for
swimming especially if i were to decide
that i would like to transition and then
start all of the hormone therapy for
multiple for a year or so then obviously
i would probably lose some muscle mass
and i would slow down in my swimming but
i don't know if that slow down would
necessarily be enough to make it fair
for the cis females it wouldn't the
studies have shown that they still
maintain even up to three years in terms
of bone density heightened speed muscle
mass so just wanted to make that clear
again studies in the link
the below of it is that you're possibly
outing somebody
in america alone there's several places
that it's still extremely dangerous to
be an open transgender person that's a
different discussion
that you're bringing and you're right
you are right that in some places is
very dangerous to be outed as a trans
person it is
dangerous but that is not what the issue
is in the first place we're talking a
different issue and i get it and that
issue is very important but that's not
what we're talking about though
yes you guys are liking today's video
make sure you like comment okay help us
out with that youtube algorithm there's
no reason not to it's free go you're
done with any
i'm going to do the last section because
like sports should be gender
everybody's neutral
vessel it shouldn't matter whether
you're male or female because i feel
like the sport like sports in general is
growing as much as this like little girl
in wrestling she wrestled in the junior
division in wrestling and nationals in
the under six pound division and she
kicked all the guys yeah at that age
there's oh my god
oh my god see if these people had their
way oh my god if these people had their
way they would destroy female sports you
would never have any supreme female
athletes at the highest level go look at
the olympics the times the scores are
not even close
these guys these people literally want
to destroy female sports
no i mean that's not their goal
it doesn't matter it's not their goal
but that's going to be the end point
the road to hell is paid with good
intentions yeah there you go i'm good
listen ask fema athletes if they want
this and all of them are going to be
like no we got gender neutral sports
they know not if they work
professionally you would never hear
about serena williams you would never
hear about any of these naomi saka never
hear about none of them they would no
longer exist i was like go for you
um so i feel like as sports growing as
we're evolving as a society and we're
being very progressive
that it should get to the point we're
talking about gender-neutral bathrooms
why can't we talk about gender neutral
sports i actually wrote and um showed
equestrian for 10 years and i was like
one of two uh men at the time and then
there are other roller derby leagues
that are co-ed and they work fine like
women are going up against men and
they're bashing each other and they're
like going at it there's a lot of things
and i feel like sports are one of these
things where it's like it has to be this
or it has to be that the same as gender
it has to be this or it has to be that
it's not
for me the issue that i would start
seeing with this is when we start
looking at scholarships and for college
level if you start combining the sports
by gender then scholarships are always
given to the top athletes what happens
to the females that now need that
scholarship necessarily to go to college
but now you've just all thrown them into
one category it all of a sudden breaks
that whole opportunity for them to maybe
even go to college because now they've
been training to be able to provide for
themselves in college and now since it's
all one level playing field maybe they
can beat the males but on average they
probably won't be able to especially
depending on the sport so trans athletes
aren't getting scholarships either i won
i've been i'm a two-time champion high
school thank you scholarship
because i didn't get my scholarship none
of the other [ __ ] get it either [ __ ]
y'all
yeah i just now maybe my scholarship
three years into being on email team but
we're talking like hypothetically in the
perfect world of sports was gender yeah
and that's not something like it's all
hypothetical yeah and everything's
hypothetical in a sense because we don't
have enough analytics
i feel as though making all sports
gender neutral in that way there is
still some
biological uh benefits to being born a
man versus being born a female i just
can't get over the fact that there are
going to be all these very obvious
differences not advantages but just
differences in if we had gender-neutral
sports it's not going to be a co-ed team
versus an all-male team it's going to be
a team versus a co-ed team so it would i
feel like there would still be strategy
that would have to be played into it i'm
thinking more like individually
individually and i can see like where
you're coming from that and you
mentioned wrestling earlier just the
whole combat sport community in general
it does have a long way to go um
definitely not completely supportive of
trans athletes but in a sense of like
when i've noticed and just like studying
how like female athletes are and male
athletes are the best like mma female
athletes cis have male training partners
and most of the time like they're
kicking their ass ah we're good we're
good we're good we're good
we're good i'm gonna just finish this
argument no no no no no no no no no no
no finish it unless like they're
training for or unless they have
somebody's better than to push them and
that's just making them a better athlete
in my opinion like kids are extremely
accepting i have two gorgeous kids
we're good i think we're good here all
right this is a terrible video it's a
terrible video
uh julie you need to cast better this is
a terrible video because it doesn't
represent well what
there's got to be better people that
choose from the trans camp to represent
these arguments because it's already a
contentious subject
and i think the trans camp
generally is not well viewed on this
topic so getting people who
misrepresented or let me rephrase who
can't represent it well come on here and
say nonsense absolute nonsense um is
disappointing so that would be what i
would say i write this video a zero out
of ten i don't know what to tell you you
know what let me rephrase i'm gonna give
it a two out of ten because the people
who had to bring the other argument did
a good job and did so in a smart calm
peaceful way and had great counterpoints
i just think unfortunately it wasn't a
great discussion it was like
this side says something this side goes
completely left this eye said something
then they counter what this eye says and
then they say something really stupid
again it was just it wasn't a good back
and forth so that was my thoughts on it
there's nothing else to add here
it's a little
a bit of a waste
[Music]
me